hello everybody and welcome to a brand
new video today we're going to be going
over something uh that a couple of
people asked me about and that is how to
find profitable items to flip on G
tracker cuz a lot of people are noticing
that um if you use the the flip finder
tabs a lot of the items that show up
near the top are well they're viewed by
a lot of people the site's growing more
people are becoming aware of it and the
items get contested a bit more because
they show up at the top for everyone now
the way get to get around that is by
using the filters as well as a couple
other uh ways you can kind of find more
unique flips to yourself uh for anyone
that's not aware G tracker is a website
that is kind of sponsoring me and uh
they have uh a lot of tools to help you
find profitable flips in RuneScape and
the link will be in the description
there uh Shameless promotion I'll get
money if you uh sign up through my link
blah blah blah blah blah okay uh so if
we jump into um let's say the a highest
margin tab so we're showing right now uh
the highest margins in RuneScape I'm not
really sure why the Twisted bows in at
the top uh that's a little weird uh but
you can see the ancestral hat is showing
a 4 mil GP margin uh which it might be
true but not everyone for one can flip
this item because they might not have
enough money and uh a lot of people will
see this near the top of their
screen and uh you can see also another
important factor is to actually look at
the item and see that well this seems
very strangely low at the time so this
might not be an actual 4 mil flip anyway
that might be for for another video so
if we go back to the highest margin tab
what we're going to do is filter the
items so we come over here to the filter
items page we're shown uh bo well I
guess 10 different filters the main ones
I use are the price minimum and price
maximum and the buying quantity Min and
uh the selling quantity minimum is good
as well um sometimes use the maximum but
not as much and um the byy price age is
useful but I usually don't touch those
too much and uh uh I'm not really sure
what these do to be honest um but we'll
go ahead and just put a minimum price in
so say you're looking for an item
between Z and 1
mil and uh let's just have a look at
that so it's going to populate now with
um of these 283 items here uh 200 of
them are under 1 mil and it's going to
show you the best flip out of all of
them now the Arcus Hood seems to have
108k margin which
is crazy uh for the item
uh which is another filter needs to kind
of be put on here but we're just doing a
quick look at it first so let's just
have a look down to the day here and um
and we can see that the item doesn't
really trade a lot so the margin can be
skewed a lot uh might still be worth
doing you might able to pick up some but
uh we might want to filter down more so
if we go back to our filter here uh now
we want to also add in a buying quantity
minimum what this is going to do is
going to get rid of all those obscure
items uh I put at least five uh five
will tell me at least some are traded
every hour pretty well and uh helps you
narrow down items like this that might
be good to snag but if you're not really
looking for that type of flip might not
be the best so after the update it's
showing the Elder chaos Hood near the
top band of sides and these are items I
have done in the past and do work pretty
well another thing with worth noting is
that the G limit will be displayed here
if it's uh been verified uh which is
pretty nice uh so let's have a look at
the Elder chaos Hood uh so we can see
with about five traded every hour
there's about 100 uh to 200 traded a day
which is totally fine you probably flip
a couple of these every hour um and get
maybe a 30k margin which would be pretty
good uh another thing I do is once I've
uh made a search like this narrow down
some items I pretty much always just add
them to my favorited list uh cuz that
will give me a bigger um searching pool
of items uh later on so I mean they
don't have to be all good at items but
I'm still going to add them on here
because it'll let me search through all
these items later as opposed to just the
uh 200 or 250 that this tab has next up
we're going to go to the high volume tab
uh now for this I filter a little bit
different uh obviously because the items
don't tend to be very
expensive now the the best filter I find
for here is uh mostly the buying
quantities because the price usually
isn't very high and most people can
afford the item uh just whether or not
um you want to but that being said I
will still use this filter because I do
see some Merit in doing it uh so let's
say we just want to find
a an item that's maybe only between 200
and 500 we're going for a pretty small
margin and we want at least
10,000 traded a day
or um per hour
sorry and that look looks good and then
we'll save the filter and we'll see what
comes
up all right so uh there we go so the
diamond bolt e seems to be near the top
now this has 73,000 traded per hour uh
and an 8 GP margin now obviously for any
item especially in the high volume tab
you're just better off going and
checking it yourself after um but still
the idea is there so uh the diamond bolt
you could flip uh well the G limits not
there so that's what's really useful
when there is a limit cuz it really
quickly shows you uh what the limit is
on the item uh roughly if the margin is
going to be good again you definitely
want to change that um but it gives you
some good ideas and once again I'm just
going to add them all to my favorite
list and now just for another test I'm
going to come over to the GE limit tab
uh because it does have uh some
different items there than the other tab
does and we'll just do another search
let's try minimum uh say we want a
little more expensive item here um
although since there's a limit on them
they might not be such expensive items
but let's try between 500k and 5
mil and we'll do a minimum buying
quantity of 10 this time and then a
minimum selling quantity of 10 as well
and we'll see what that filters down to
all right we actually decided to change
the buying limit to five uh or so the
buying quantity so now we're left with
the saden dehy boots as our number one
uh flip which might be kind of good
let's have a look has a limit of 125
which is pretty nice on an item that's
this
expensive and it says it has a 30k
margin now we can look down to the day
and see how many roughly are traded uh
per hour maybe 10 or 15 an hour uh if we
get to the day we can see how much I
traded a day so
like 100 to 300 more
recently and yeah you could easily get
uh probably Mill if you managed to flip
all these you need a lot of starting
cash but anyway get the idea and lastly
for the tabs we're going to go to the
favorite item tab now this isn't really
set up until you've favored a bunch of
items of course you can put your
favorite items there for sure if you
just want to actually look at the items
you do all the time uh but for that you
can just use a search function as well
uh what i' like to do is just add a
crapload of items to my favorite pages
and then it gives you um a lot of leeway
to see what the item like you have a
bigger searching pool to look through
your items now the filter is not
currently working on this page and I
have brought that up with the owner so
hopefully that will actually get added
in the next day or two uh but once you
do have the filter available you will be
able to add a ton of items to your
favorite items page and then filter
through those so you can actually kind
of make a custom uh pool of items you're
going to filter through but for now I
have about 350 items added and then we
can just filter using these top bars
here which are still useful not as good
but uh so if we look at say the
approximate profit
Twisted bows at the top prayer scroll
all the new items pretty well um but we
can still get an idea of what items
might be profitable just from uh these
column filter kind of things but again
hopefully the actual uh inbuilt filters
will be added pretty soon and very last
uh another feature that is probably kind
of hidden to most and is going to be
extremely useful for those who are using
a free-to-play account is actually in
your account settings you can add a f2p
filter onto your entire account so it's
kind of like a free-to-play setting so
we've gone and turned it on it's just
under account and then under account
settings and it'll just be called uh
freet toop playay filter or something
like that and now all the tabs uh except
for your favorite items tabs will
include only free toplay items excluded
from the pay to-play items so if we have
a quick look at the flip finder now if
we go to suggested
items you notice that they are all free
to play uh highest margins is really
useful if you're free to play flipper
right now the green de oh right no so we
still got some filters on so we'll take
the filters off just for
now and everything I've shown you will
work exactly the same for free to play
items it's just going to be less
profitable items cuz they're free to
play but you can see here the guilded
two-handed sword is a freeo play item it
has 190k margin on it uh so extremely
useful for those who are flipping in
freeo play works for all the tabs as
well uh except for the uh favorite items
tab so hope you guys enjoyed the video
and found uh some useful information
here I really didn't know about that
freet toplay uh setting which is going
to be extremely useful for other people
who aren't actually a members at the
time and if you want to see more uh
videos on G tracker definitely leave the
video a like so I know and I'll see you
guys in the next video
[Music]